hey guys it is top five time which means
I'm here to fill you in on five of the
biggest things that happened in gaming
this
[Music]
week first up lindsy Lo and GTA 5 are
together again in the news this week and
it turns out she's still pretty pierced
about take to interactive supposedly
nicking Her Image the chick who was also
both twins in The Parent Trap filed a 67
page complaint against Take 2
interactive and Rockstar claiming they
benefited from using her likeness and
that they used her as a reference for
the character Lacy Jonas in case you
wanted to know the main similarity seems
to be that they're both young blonde
women and take two actively challenging
the
allegation so many people are playing
Destiny 3.2 million people specifically
bunge Community Manager David D revealed
the Monumental figure which represents
the average number of players every day
on average their sessions are about 3
hours they log into the game 1.8 times a
day and they play Destiny 20.9 times in
total Bungie have said more players are
online with Destiny now in comparison to
similar banss for Halo 3 and Halo Reach
combined although to be fair those games
had offline single player campaigns and
Destiny is always
online Bill Spencer has commented on
Microsoft's controversial Indie policy
which says that games need to Launch on
the Xbox One at the same time as they do
on other platforms the policy does not
allow an indie developer to release
their game on the Xbox One if it's
already been made available on other
platforms Spencer claims the moves to
make Xbox owners feel first class even
when it comes to indie game launches he
went on to say that Xbox are trying hard
to work with Indie devs to alleviate
development issues caused by the claw
namely making a game for multiple
platforms at the same time nonetheless
rethink thinking the policy may not be
totally out of the question as criticism
of the Clause has been acknowledged by
Spencer the game hatred came into our
lives this week and it's caused some
concern for some Gamers given that it
seems to revolve around the mass
murdering of unarmed civilians warning
violent images follow the game is
developed on Unreal Engine 4 although
owner of said engine epic games have
been quick to distance themselves from
the trailer hatred Dev destructive
Creations have assured that they really
do intend to release the game publicly
the dev have said the plan is for you to
spread Armageddon across Society in the
game although they did warn not to try
what you see in the game at home and
simply enjoy it for what it
is Capcom are apparently going hard or
going home saying that a game needs to
sell over 2 million copies to be
considered for a sequel Capcom producer
Yosi Nori Ono told famitsu how the
company approaches sequels by saying if
a game doesn't sell over 2 million
copies then we'd have to put the breakes
on any plans for a sequel all that means
is we weren't capable enough and all we
can do after that is to reflect on the
experience take what we can learn from
it and try to apply those lessons on
some other title recent Capcom games
that have yet to hit 2 million include
DmC Devil May Cry Dead Rising 3 and
Dragon's Dogma let me know what you
think about this cap policy jing a game
needs to be super successful to earn a
sequel or is that unfair this week on
site be sure to check out six awesome
games you can look forward to this year
on the chist we turn into kleptomaniacs
on Skyrim mods and Mary takes on The
Evil Within that is it for me this week
thanks for sticking around be sure to
have yourself an awesome weekend and
I'll catch you again on
[Music]
Monday